il y a évidemment des fortes
interactions qui sont connues et
documentées entre les États et les
principaux groupes pétroliers depuis la
découverte du pétrole s'est mise en
place une sorte de véritable diplomatie
du pétrole ou pétrroipomatie et c'est
vrai que euh connaissant assez bien le
le continent africain pour y mener de
nombreuses recherches je suis toujours
frappé notamment de l'implantation de
Total énergie dans de nombreux pays
africains euh vous savez par exemple
qu'en ce moment a lieu la Coupe
d'Afrique des nations qui a él un
événement très important pour le
continent le principal sponsor de cet
événement c'est total ennergie au point
d'ailleurs que Total que cette compagnie
a obtenu le fait que officiellement la
Coupe d'Afrique des nations soit
désignée Coupe d'Afrique des nations
totale énergie et donc a même acheté des
droits sur le nom même de Coupe
d'Afrique des Nations de la même manière
en Ouganda qui est un pays qui a
beaucoup fait parler de luoui en raison
de de l'éoduc hicop qui est très
contesté ayant passé beaucoup de temps
en Nou anda en raison de mes recherches
sur lesmigration puisque l'Ouganda
apparaît souvent comme un pays modèle en
matière d'accueil des réfugiés et je
suis frappé de voir comme il y a une
station totale énergie quasiment tous
les 100 m sur quelques route que l'on
aille en ouanda et donc bien entendu ne
m'apparaî pas ici de juger l'imbrication
entre compagnie pétrolière et
gouvernement mais il est certain qu'il y
a une très forte implantation et à
l'évidence une stratégie d'influence à
tout le moins commercial